yours is the business of giving and  learning your work of art  a lifetime your fulfillment will always  lie in your creative  pression not in its product so look  beyond the brick Bats the critics and  know within you that you always have a  choice between barter and creation life  as a creator will always be a tightrope  so do not try to feed your stomach with  creativity it is food for the soul not  your stomach do not be afraid to do defy  conventions do not be afraid to destroy  systems that kill art and your souls do  not be afraid to be hungry and do not be  afraid to walk alone if necessary  because on a tightrope we all walk alone  and remember if you are a creator  you're a fine ambulance and not very  many people know what it means let alone  be it so be a phenom be list is my  prayer to all you creative people here  at Yale tonight